dos particularidades plantea esta nueva
caravana que ella es la número 16 del
2022 la primera es el volumen de
personas se habla de más de 4000
individuos que marchan desde Tapachula
hasta Huixtla y este número de porcilla
plantea todo un reto para las
autoridades migratorias así como ejerce
una presión para que les entreguen el
ansiado documento el formato múltiple de
migración que tanto les niegan en
Tapachula pero que aspiran a que se los
entreguen en wix live la segunda
particularidad es que la Comisión
Nacional de Derechos Humanos de México
decretó medidas cautelares para que sean
las propias autoridades migratorias
quienes garanticen la protección
humanitaria de estas 4.000 personas
porque hay 1.200 que son niños mujeres
embarazadas a quienes se les debe dar
los insumos necesarios de agua suero y
atención médica para que a lo largo de
la marcha no tengan complicaciones de
salud Andrés usted es que estuvo
cubriendo recientemente este fenómeno de
las caravanas de migrantes de
Centroamérica hacia Estados Unidos
porque se quejan los de estrellarse con
un muro de burocracia a su llegada a
México
bueno justamente a diferencia del
tránsito por los otros países
Centroamericanos donde se suele pagar un
salvoconducto a las autoridades
migratorias de cada país para poder
atravesarlo en México no no se maneja
esta modalidad y esta pachula la donde
se levanta un muro burocrático a donde
también la están llamando de tapón de
Tapachula haciendo una analogía con el
tapón de Darién porque allí les exigen
que se presenten ante la comarca que es
la comisión para los derechos de los
refugiados y realicen un trámite que
puede tardar entre 4 y 6 meses los
migrantes no cuentan con este tiempo y
quedan bloqueados quedan frenados en
Tapachula entonces solo tienen dos
opciones una que es a través de estas
caravanas migrar en masa para poder
cumplir su objetivo de llegar hasta la
frontera sur de los Estados Unidos o2
poner su vida en riesgo al contratar a
traficantes de personas los denominados
polleros o coyotes